this winter bone sisters helped to feed
those who are in poor conditions and who
don't even have a clothing to keep
themselves warm your small donation
might mean nothing to you but it can
change their life and help them survive
the winter this year this is your next
opponent
[Music]
top two opponents
right if you want to come and taste this
you want some Halal medicine come see me
you get me
did you see that the 10 punches what you
didn't see on camera
you [ __ ] so yeah to say too quick for
the framework it's too quick
Give Me Five Points not free
I hate it I hate every second
cash is like marmalade you either love
them I hate him
this is my muffin but I hate him
go five seconds five seconds
on this one my defense is impregnable
I'm Alexander I'm gonna eat your kids
we don't hit the face for this Harem you
know why not cut those kidneys I smash
your liver I'll come for your heart you
can't breathe after I hit you I've been
near 250 calories usually it takes me a
good 15 minute job to do that so high
intensity training is as good as that
100 so what we're gonna do now we're
gonna hit the bags get me so if any
other far right try to call me on the
road
that we hit with a left hook and a right
uppercut
every night
and then 10 seconds when they move a
very um relaxed intensity so the heart
rate goes up and goes down up and goes
down and they get used to operate when
the fatigue
before you pull your head
[Music]
this is too much
it's terrible I hate himself
thank you so much
it's worth it
that's me it's worth it
yeah
well sisters anything that you do in
mind if there's no hardship you're going
to see the consequences on the wrong one
anything that you do bringing your kids
up to work to training anything that we
do in the beginning it's hard but in the
long life these follows so anytime that
Allah says in the Quran comes is the
opposite is true with ease called
hardships so I'd rather go off into
hardship now hate every second of here
but in the long run the things that
follows and helps me it's not much
better be immense technologically or
spiritually so that's why I come here
you think I love doing this but I also
love it I love the fact that I came I
did it
do what it's easy the easiest thing I
can do sit on the sofa and watch TV go
on YouTube play games or whatever maybe
I prefer to be here especially for the
men for investment emasculated yeah
testosterone levels are being the lowest
since ever yeah in history they're
feeling down in research the hand group
of men shaking each other's hands is in
the softest they have ever encountered
in history are you mad you mad
careful come on
dude of course
[Music]
so we're gonna put the boys through the
circuit now it's a body weight circuit
after doing all the grinding work the
bag work and using stuff now using their
bodies pushing their bodies to the to
the Limit now there's something that
everyone can do at home it's so easy but
it's probably the most painful and
probably the hardest part of the workout
so let's see how they do how many
seconds
no
my back is broken
ah I'm still joking
again let's go what
up
quick up quick up quick up down
don't give me a minute
after after 15 seconds
let's go
number five
foreign
okay guys so we finished training at a
thousand calories
now
training especially if you're doing MMA
boxing is one of the hardest high
intensity training ever
every time I used to go rocks in I used
to say I'm never coming back but I still
came back it's one of those things that
you hate what you love now here we have
a shower
this shower is very unique because the
hot water doesn't work and the
temperature outside is what you feel
inside yes so
now I'm going to jump in there now this
is the part where I look forward to and
I hate the most and it goes back to
making yourself suffer sometimes we
think being in pain who would want to be
in pain why would you want to be in pain
why would someone in their right mind
cause pain to their self so guys
named the toilet so it came out but one
thing that I understood especially with
our current times with the youth having
psychological illnesses mental health
problems Etc we look at our previous
generations they didn't have this yes
they were tested there were times where
they cried this happened with The
Messengers and the best woman when she
was giving birth she said I wish I did
not exist right I wish I was I didn't I
was I didn't exist and I was not
forgotten we are not talking about
people suffering and going through Pains
of course you're going to of course
there's gonna be times where I've been
through hardships in my life and it was
so painful but I'm talking about
physical training as well brothers who
Allah is sitting at home it's the
easiest thing I can do I'm doing well I
can just sit at home have popcorn wash
stuff read my book best feeling ever but
I know on the long one I'm going to
suffer I know that's why when you look
at people like khabib yes and his father
if people saw how his father trained
when he's young you know what they'll
say this man is an oppressor this man is
oppressing his son no he's not look what
kind of a person turned out to be
physically mentally
look at his character this comes that's
why when Allah says
with hardship comes is verily with
hardship consistent if this statement is
true that with hardship comes East
opposite has to be true with ease comes
hardship and that is exactly what I
believe we are facing today with our
youngsters and my youth we've lived like
Kingdom we've got everything going for
us and what do we do any little hand
that touches us it's as if we're
finished we've been hit by the biggest
calamities why is it like brother Andrew
Taylor says why is the people in the
third world countries you don't see them
having this issue why don't they come
and see I've got this and they've got
thing going for them how is this the
cause because they have hardship and
that hardship in the long run gives them
ease so when I come and train here do
you think I like doing the training I
hate him my shoulder hurts my arms hurt
my legs hurt my stomach hurts I'm in
physical pain but I come every single
week anytime I dream
Allah is my witness the mental calmness
I have clearance in my head and my
thought process while right has a ripple
effect in my whole day so usually my
routine is every day I wake up for Fajr
do what I need to do for about half an
hour go back to sleep wake up at 10 30
am get ready hit the road at 11AM do
Quran lesson for one hour I try to
implement Quran in my every day for one
hour minimum here there's no way I can
come and train my body and neglect my
soul it's really out of your mind yeah
that's why I believe somebody she trains
their body and not their soul is a weak
person as somebody who trains their soul
and not their body as a person that's
you you know he's making some efforts
you know he's progressing as somebody
who trains his body and his soul is a
martial like somebody who's doing I'm
not trying to praise myself I try my
best 11 am to 12. when I want to do my
final set in the car memorization
because obviously I can't read in the
car and I go on the motorway and our
journey the person who sent him said
when you buy a house buy a house not a
house if you live in a house make your
choice spacious it has an impact on the
way you think when I'm on the motorway
and I see Open Fields and trees and the
Sun and the sky it really open it gives
me positivity and then I come here at 12
around quarter past two after I will
start training for about an hour and an
hour 20 minutes as you saw after that I
got hit the cold freezing shower which I
hate and after that before training
praise the Lord after training prayer
is done spiritually mentally
psychologically spiritually good for the
day and I can't spend time with my
family or if I need to go to work I do
work so all I'm saying is brother
sisters don't forget like Allah says
verily with hardship comes these in
indeed with hardship comes easy live
your hardship now so the ease and the
long run follows inshallah I'm gonna
take the shower if you guys want to hear
what that sounds like you can join me
Sub-Zero brother
whoosh
probably your hands are so cold you're
gonna have to defrost them in the
microwave 30 minutes
yeah I need to go now you know I don't
want to cause a fit not you know sisters
please don't watch this yeah
it's freezing
this guy is freezing bro absolutely
freezing